WE'RE READY. ALL RIGHT? DOES
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER? WE'RE LIVE IN
ROOM 2200 OF THE SWING SPACE.
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE GOT A QUORUM
HERE. I'LL ASK ANY OTHER MEMBERS
TO COME ON DOWN. WE HAVE ONE
URGENCY MEASURE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, WHICH WILL START AFTER
THE TRIVIA QUESTIONS. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS INDICATED THEY DO
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS MEASURE
AND WILL NOT BE HERE. SO LET'S
ESTABLISH OUR CORE. PORTANTINO
I'M HERE. PORTANTINO HERE. JONES
JONES. HERE ASHBY ASHBY. HERE
BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE, SARTO.
WAHHAB WAHAB HERE, WIENER. WE
HAVE A QUORUM, RIGHT? WE HAVE A
QUORUM. UH, BEFORE WE, UH GO TO
MR HOLDEN. I DO WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE THINGS. THIS WILL BE MY
LAST HEARING. I BELIEVE AS CHAIR
AND SO I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE STAFF OF THIS
COMMITTEE ROCK. SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. AND ALL OF YOU WHO WE
ONLY HAVE TWO OF YOU HERE, BUT
THE REST OF YOU. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS OF YOUR SERVICE TO OUR
STATE AND TO OUR MY COLLEAGUES
HERE AS WELL. IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE BEING, UH, YOUR
COMMITTEE CHAIR, SO THANK YOU
ALL FOR SERVING. ON THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU WITH THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO TRIVIA. MR.
HOLDEN. I'M GOING TO GO TO
TRIVIA, OK? SO WHO KNOWS HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE PLAYED WONDER
WOMAN? I GET TO TOTAL. WE'RE
DOING WONDER WOMAN TRIVIA. LIKE
BLOCKBUSTER, YOU KNOW, TOTAL
NUMBER OF WOMEN ANIMATED MOVIES.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HINT. WELL ON Tð
VÆ IN ANIMATION. 00 OK, WELL,
THEN WE COULD ADD TWO DOES
ANYBODY KNOW I'VE GOT 11. 11. SO
I'LL DO TRUE OR FALSE WAS LINDA
CARTER? A WONDER WOMAN? YES.
TRUE YES, WAS ROSARIO ROSARIO
DAWSON. WONDER WOMAN. YEAH. THIS
IS A VOICE SHE WAS JUSTICE
LEAGUE THRONE OF ATLANTIS
CARTOON MICHELLE MONAGHAN. YES
JUSTICE LEAGUE WORE 2014. MAGGIE
QUÊ. I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THAT
IS. YES YOUNG JUSTICE 2010. LUCY
LAWLESS. YES. WHO SAID YES. LUCY
LAWLESS THE NEW FRONTIER 2008
JUSTICE LEAGUE. KATHIE LEE
CROSBY. UH YES, 2000 OR EXCUSE
ME, 1974. CATHY AND CROSBY AND
THEN THE ONE THAT THREW ME. DID
YOU GOT A TRUE OR FALSE? THE
BRADY KIDS SPAWNED A WONDER
WOMAN. SPIN OFF. YOU'RE A
BELIEVER. IT'S TRUE. THERE WAS
ACTUALLY THE BRADY KIDS JANE
WEBB IN 1972 PLAYED WONDER WOMAN
. AND, OF COURSE, GIL GOODELL
PLAYED WONDER WOMAN, SO THAT'S
OUR WONDER WOMAN TRIVIA AND I
HAVE A FEW MORE LATER. BUT LET'S
GO TO MR HOLDEN. MR HOLDEN, WE
HAVE A B 610, WHICH IS A DUE
PASS RECOMMENDATION, PLEASE.
THERE. OBVIOUSLY KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE FISCAL ASPECT OR
A TRIVIA QUESTION. WE DO ACCEPT
TRIVIA QUESTIONS. OK UM, I'M
GONNA KEEP IT QUICK. WHAT FAMOUS
BASEBALL PLAYER PLAYED POINT
GUARD ON MR HOLDEN'S COLLEGE
BASKETBALL TEAM. I WAS THERE.
SEE I GAVE HIM A SOFTBALL. BUT
DID YOU ALL KNOW THAT TONY GWYNN
WAS THE POINT GUARD THAT HELPED
MR HOLDEN SCORE ALL THOSE
POINTS? DID YOU KNOW THAT? YEAH,
BUT SEE THAT ANYWAY, JUST TO
THROW AN IMPROMPTU AND MR HOLDEN
WAS THE PRIDE OF WOOD HIGH
SCHOOL MUIR OR P HÌ S¼, WHO
KNOWS HÌ S¼. THERE YOU GO. ALL
RIGHT, MR HOLDEN. TELL US ABOUT
YOUR BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPO. HARD MAN. UM LET'S
SAY FIRST OF ALL, LET ME THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS, UH,
FOR, UM, CONVENING THIS MEETING
TODAY AS YOU RECALL. LAST YEAR,
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A B 1228, WHICH
CREATED A PATH FORWARD TO
RESOLVE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
CONCERNS AROUND THE CONTENT OF A
B 257. WHILE PRESERVING FAST
FOOD WORKERS HARD FOUGHT EFFORTS
TO SECURE A SEAT AT THE TABLE IN
MEANS TO RAISE STANDARDS.
HOWEVER PRIOR TO THE CLOSE OF
SESSION LAST YEAR, I SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL INDICATING
THAT I WANTED TO CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF ONE ASPECT OF 1228.
THERE IS A NEED TO EXEMPT
ADDITIONAL RESTAURANTS FROM THE
DEFINITION OF FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT, INCLUDING SUCH
RESTAURANTS AND AIRPORTS, HOTELS
, EVENT CENTERS, THEME PARKS,
MUSEUMS AND CERTAIN OTHER
LOCATIONS, WHILE AB 1228
ESTABLISHES A MINIMUM WAGE OF
$20 PER HOUR STARTING APRIL 1ST
OF THIS YEAR THIS BILL A B 610
EXEMPTS THE ABOVE MENTIONED
PASTORS, RESTAURANTS, MANY OF
WHOM HAVE HISTORICAL
HISTORICALLY ESTABLISHED
COMPENSATION AND WORKING
CONDITIONS IN EXCESS OF THE
STANDARD SET BY 1228. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
WITH THAT. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES? UH, JUST FOR
TECHNICAL PURPOSES, ALL RIGHT,
TECHNICAL PURPOSES, ALL RIGHT.
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS? MOVE THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
QUESTION. DOCTOR JONES. DID YOU
WANT TO TAKE PUBLIC AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION? I WILL DO THAT. OK,
FIRST I ASK FOR WITNESSES, AND
THEN WE HAD A MOTION AND THEN TO
YOU, I WILL. WHATEVER YOU IF I
CAN SPEAK NOW OR I CAN WAIT TO
THE WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OFFICE TO SUPPORT
GO AHEAD. YOU CAN. OH, I WAS
GONNA ANSWER THE TECHNICAL
QUESTION THAT I AM IN SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? WE HAVE OPPOSITION. YOU
GUYS JUST KEEP MOVING AROUND.
BUT YOU'RE LIKE FAINTING,
WHETHER YOU'RE COMING TO THE
PODIUM OR NOT. YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
COME TO THE PODIUM. IT'S
ROSENBERGER WITH SERVES
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION IN
SUPPORT. MARIO ER WITH UNITE
HERE. THE HOSPITALITY WORKERS IN
SUPPORT. AMY HIND SCHEICH WITH
UNITE HERE. LOCAL 11 IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL? SEEING NÓ OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. NOW WE'LL COME BACK TO
MR JONES. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. I
JUST WANTED TO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY, BUT I
THINK THIS BILL KIND OF
UNDERSCORES THE CHALLENGES WITH
THE ORIGINAL BILL A B 1228. YOU
KNOW, OPERATORS OF ALL KINDS OF,
UH, RESTAURANTS IN MY DISTRICT
ARE ARE REALLY UPSET ABOUT 1228,
AND THEY THINK IT'S GONNA BE A
BIG PROBLEM FOR THEIR BUSINESS.
AND UM, I THINK WE SHOULD EXEMPT
A LOT MORE, UH, RESTAURANTS OUT
OF THIS OR LET'S JUST UNDO 1228
ALTOGETHER. UH BUT I'M I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
THAT WE WILL KEEP MOVING IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION IN, UH,
DEALING WITH 1228. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS?
WE HAVE A MOTION, MR HOLDEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST TO
SAY THAT THE REASON THAT THIS
BILL IS BEFORE US IS BECAUSE
THERE ARE HOTEL OPERATORS AND
OTHERS THAT ARE CAUGHT IN A
SITUATION WHERE $20 AN HOUR IS
THE FLOOR AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE HELD TO THAT. THEY'RE TRYING
TO EXCEED THAT TO 25 OR $30 OR
$40 AN HOUR AND SO THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE BEING ACCEPTED FROM THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
AGAIN. I APPRECIATE FOLKS
WORKING THIS OUT AND BEING ON
THE SAME PAGE THAT'S HELPFUL
WITH THAT. WE WILL TAKE A VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO A JONES JONES, I,
ASHBY ASHBY. I BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I èC RTO WAHAB. WELL
HÌ I WIENER WIENER. I 06 TO
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. WHO WHO
ARE WE MISSING? HE'S NOT OUT. WE
HAVE ONE LAST TRIVIA QUESTION
BEFORE EVERYBODY GOES. WHAT WAS
THE NAME OF THE VERY FIRST
SENATE PRO TEM? FIRST VERY
FIRST. DECEMBER 15TH 1849 TO
JANUARY 9TH 1851 JUST OVER A
YEAR. VERY POPULAR MAN NAMED
HENRY E, KIRBY CHAMBERLAIN.
THAT'S OUR FINAL TRIVIA QUESTION
. THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING I DO
NOT KNOW. THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
GOOD FOR ME TO LOOK UP. BY THE
WAY YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE WONDER
WOMAN STUFF. IF YOU'RE CURIOUS
IF YOU LIKE THAT, ALL RIGHT,
EVERYBODY, THANK YOU. AND AGAIN,
MY STAFF, YOU GUYS ROCK AND
PLEASE TELL MARK I WISH HIM
WELL, I KNOW HE'S UNDER THE
WEATHER TODAY SO AND THANK YOU,
EVERYBODY FOR INDULGING ME
THROUGHOUT THIS LAST FIVE YEARS
AND THROUGH COVID THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.